I don't have the best news today for the
progressive movement in the context of
the 2020 Democratic primary now I know
that there will be people who write to
me and say David these are the wrong
polls this is not trustworthy or
whatever but I do it when progressives
are up and I do it when progressives are
down because I'm reporting to you what
is going on out there and the latest
polls those that have been released
within the last couple of days show Joe
Biden with one of the largest national
leads going all the way back to December
of 2019 and it gives me no pleasure to
tell you this but this I don't do what
Trump does right when the stock market's
up Trump tweets about it when the stock
markets down he says nothing or
sometimes we'll say I don't pay much
attention to the stock market
Bernie surged recently and we covered it
and lately Joe Biden has recovered and I
actually don't fully understand what's
going on in addition to that after some
very strong showings from Bernie Sanders
in Iowa Joe Biden is also in the lead
there in a recent poll of course Iowa is
the first place where 2020 voting will
happen very soon on February 3rd so
let's go through it step by step first
through the national polls the latest
poll from survey USA says Biden 32
Sanders 21 Warren 14 that is Biden plus
11 and this is the biggest lead Biden
has had in a national poll going back to
one released in late December where
Biden was plus 13 now also shockingly in
this poll Michael Bloomberg is polling 9
not everybody believes that so
understandably there's some skepticism
here I don't know that I believe
Bloomberg has 9
I don't know that Biden is really plus
11 but clearly as we continue to get
closer and closer to the votes starting
Joe Biden is doing well here at the
national level now let's go and look at
Iowa the big story two weeks ago in Iowa
was that Bernie Sanders took a lead in
an important Iowa poll the Des Moines
Register poll the first state to vote
February 3rd it's a caucus format and
Bernie took a lead in the Des Moines
Register poll 20 to 17
over Elizabeth Warren there is a 3.7
margin of error but it was important
because Bernie clearly had the momentum
at the time the last couple of polls for
Bernie and Iowa are not as good the
latest Monmouth poll has Joe Biden
leading in Iowa 24 to 18 over Bernie the
latest focus on rural America poll Joe
Biden is plus 6 over Warren with Bernie
only at 14 in Iowa again you don't have
to believe any particular poll is
exactly right but if this is even
remotely accurate Bernie might end up
with 0 delegates in Iowa because
remember you need 15% to get any
delegates in primaries now the question
is can we trust these polls and what
does this tell us about the dynamics of
the Democratic primary let's do can we
trust them first generally speaking you
can trust these polls ok there's a
margin of error we know that Bernie
Sanders down 10 in Iowa is outside of
the margin of error maybe he's really
only down 6 or something like that all
we can do is wait and see and support
the person we want what I think is going
on here is the more important question
and what's going on as exactly as we
predicted the entire Warren Bernie
dust-up about Bernie said a woman can't
win to Elizabeth Warren back in 2018
it's not about drastically moving
support between Bernie and Warren
I think it's basically clear at this
point that Elizabeth Warren does not
have a serious path to securing the
Democratic nomination it's about
muddling things up it's about making
both Bernie and Warren seem just kind of
troublesome and buy time for Joe Biden
in first place to get to those first
votes to let Joe Biden start
accumulating Delegates and build
establishment momentum in that way I
told you this before when the entire
thing started the Bernie Warren scandal
or pseudo scandal it's not going to get
Elizabeth Warren into the lead it's
going to reinforce the establishment it
gives Biden more time in first place to
be seen in first place to reinforce
being in first place
that is the way it works that's what
we're seeing right now now if you
disagree with miry
of what's going on let me know but
unfortunately this was predictable this
is exactly what we anticipated now in
terms of other early states New
Hampshire is second to vote Bernie is
still leading there by one to five
depending on the poll you look at that's
great for the progressive movement at
the same time historically New Hampshire
is not super important in determining
who wins the Democratic primary Nevada
votes third Biden is leading every
recent poll there we only have two from
2020 Biden is plus 1 and plus 6 that
could also shift and then forth to vote
is South Carolina South Carolina has
always been very easily in Joe Biden's
camp Joe Biden leading by more than 20
points in the latest Fox News poll then
you get to California and Bernie is
ahead in a number of recent polls in
California not every poll bura Biden is
actually ahead by 10 points in one
recent California poll I really have no
idea what's going on in California I'm
guessing that multiple candidates will
scoop up delegates there what's
important to understand about the math
is unless a really long shot candidate
gets a bunch of Delegates in California
if the leaders Biden Bernie and Warren
each pick up a similar number of
Delegates in California it doesn't
really change the dynamics very much
because they're just kind of splitting
delegates and then it comes down to the
states where it's not close but we'll
have a more detailed assessment of
possible delegate counts as the voting
starts this is the reality we have and I
know some people will write to me and
say David but you're not giving enough
credence to this one poll that has
Bernie up one or something like that
these are the trends okay these are the
trends I understand that not every poll
is going to confirm what we might
believe is going on but if we zoom out
and look at the trends Biden is
continuing to just remain there in that
front-runner position in a lot of key
states and now nationally something is
going to have to happen and relatively
quickly for a progressive to have a shot
Warren increasingly seems mathematically
almost out at this point when it comes
to a path to the nomination Bernie's
still in it but the numbers are going to
have to shift in his favor if that's
going to become a
let me know what you think about my read
on all of this so you're someone who
enjoys thinking about politics you love
learning about countless other topics
but you just don't have enough time in
your week to read or listen to all the
books you've been meaning to get to
blink astiz an app that will completely
transform the way that you absorb
information and ideas because what they
do is take thousands of non-fiction
books extract the most important
insights and information and then
present each book to you as text or
audio which you can consume in just 15
minutes
imagine how well-rounded you will become
once you have the ability to read five
books in one sitting or listen to a new
book on your commute every day obviously
we should read the full versions of
books whenever we can it's what I try to
do but it is a reality that there's a
whole world of books out there that you
will never get to but blinka swill help
you get to more i just finished
listening to catch and kill by Ronan
Farrow super interesting book probably
already familiar to some in my audience
and a really interesting take at how
Harvey Weinstein and his alleged
transgressions were brought to light
excellent investigative piece you'll be
able to have conversations with people
about totally new topics you can feed
your curiosity in ways that you've never
been able to before and the best part is
it's only about eight bucks a month
which gives you unlimited access to
every single book in their catalogue
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent then blink astiz for
you